as you can see alice is your favorite  yeah and all the Maya all the money from  day one has come for a girl I wanted to  huge amount money coming in there and  made a thing to somebody knows something  that we don't and because really it  should be a task of a coin but last  night there's a bit of money for a boy  of thirteen 28 but if punters are right  who want a massive pay today it will be  a girl today named Alice at five to four  Charlotte and Elizabeth five to one and  six to one Victoria a 2-1 and the top  name if it's a boy is James at 14 21 ok  so you're still taking bets and whether  it's a boy or a girl cuz blood foots  have closed the book on that I'm saying  no we're gonna keep your own buzzer does  somebody know something i do we're going  to keep it open for as long as possible  tastic I'll let you get test out thank  you very much thanks a lot